p90x is a fitness program that provides
the ultimate alternative to the gym the
program lasts 90 straight days designed
to get participants in the best shape of
their lives
so we got for ordinary people to try the
latest version I'm hoping that it makes
me a fitter healthier person after this
I feel like this will be a good changeup
I also expect to look like Beyonce by
the end of this I just haven't really
been as active as I used to be in
college so I think now is the time to
make change I think I'm gonna be like
lean mean fighting machine really buff
hopefully still womanly buff but I think
it's gonna work
I'm kind of nervous that they're gonna
tell me I'm obese gonna confirm what I
already know that I'm a lazy piece is a
lazy yeah but this will be really
helpful though to see where we're at so
that we know kind of where we want to go
that's right they get checks and admit
realize that you know we're so thick
yeah we're gonna be badass right he told
me that I need to lose about 20 pounds
of body fat I'm only more excited to do
this p90x thing because I think the
visual progress he made for peers but
according to this I only have eight
point eight percent body fat so I need
to stop doing that and I guess focus on
just gaining muscle I did not know that
I have to lose 18 pounds of fat that is
a very large infant you need to increase
or decrease but it's fat no increase
needed in muscle mass I don't really
work out more than anybody here I'd say
they probably all work out more than me
so I get it I'm an [ __ ]
it's been tough I feel like I've had
more energy overall I would say this is
probably up there maybe top five worst
decisions I've ever made it's been going
like really well even just a week after
doing stuff I could feel my abs but I've
definitely noticed like well my shirt
fits a little better 90 days it's insane
I don't know how anybody could do this
without big force - I can already tell
them yes checking yourself out worse
again
so I just did the incinerator
well these [ __ ] send drink beer and
provided a [ __ ] commentary on my form
my body feels just like really kind of
like firm and like its height and like
Kerr and I do feel stronger I do feel
more flexible I was definitely not
flexible for this but now I'm like oh I
can do this I've definitely had to
change my life that's not true I mean I
still eat like [ __ ] I still drink I just
pay for them now
we're in the third block of p90x which
means less than 30 days to go and to be
honest I'm pretty ready for this to be
done not because I am not happy with the
results just because it's killer every
single day day in day out I am currently
in a hotel room in Europe on vacation
but since my colleagues and I have
decided to use p90x challenge I am
taking p90x with me on the road
malory we miss you man it was like this
is super easy yeah we do I'm so done
yeah 90 days is too long suspected but I
definitely I'm excited to see my results
and see you know did I do it it's the
sound muscle now what's up the thing
Daniel
45-second this is the last day of p90x
hopefully we improved guys I just want
to see like what's muscle now ready for
the finish line guys are you guys ready
my goal was to lose body fat however my
personal goal was to look like Beyonce
Leslie so my goal in the beginning of
this challenge was just to basically
lose body fat my goal was to sustain my
goal was to gain muscle mass whoa that's
super weird
so after 90 days I lost a pound of body
fat so I lost 0.2 pounds of body fat and
I lost point looks like five of muscle
mass okay so I gained two pounds of
muscle and I also gained two pounds of
fat it looks like it says that I gained
three pounds of body fat and I gained
point seven I'm about to look at a
before-and-after of uh I used to look
like before and what it look like now
yep I definitely look like I gained
muscle there's definitely considerable
difference between the two yeah it looks
like I gained definition of my back in
my arm
and on the home front they say numbers
don't lie but today they [ __ ] like oh
I look different whoa I look so
different
whoa also I think about Tanner guys I
had so much backside oh yeah I look a
lot smaller now than I did before I
don't know what to say yeah but I mean
at least I look better so that's all
that really matters to me at the end of
the day I did it okay
yeah I mean I definitely look bigger
pretty much everywhere a little bit kind
of like just uniform change in the plus
I'm happy with that I think I look good
I'm moving forward I want to just
exercise all day every day I would say
worth it
working out three or four days a week
will seem like a cakewalk I'm starting
to think more about what I could do diet
wise
I'm gonna miss doing the workouts with
them every week I think we've all grown
together in this
I think the camaraderie that came along
with it was great doing this with my
friend was kind of like the best part I
loved having my like Fitness fam like
but that's what I love most about it but
I think we could all agree that p90x was
an excruciating soul-sucking experience
and I'm extremely happy that it's over
produces results what if you do it
you're out of your mind
good on you